the US gun Market is the biggest in the
world by far gun sales across the United
States have reached record highs we
produce the most guns
and as the market in the U.S it's to
some point of saturation in other words
it's already sold 400 million guns
there's been a push by U.S gun
manufacturers to sell abroad
the problem is that the places that want
guns tend to be countries with high
crime rates a lot of political
instability or a lot of violence
thank you
there are now more guns than people in
the U.S and even though American Gun
purchases haven't slowed down
manufacturers have set their sites
outside the U.S to boost sales as well
you go back almost 20 years the assault
rifle ban expires in 2004 and that
pushes gun manufacturers to start to
develop new lines of guns including
AR-15 style guns
at the same time the gun industry and
individual gun companies start trying to
tap International markets as a way to
grow more sales
and so the U.S manufacturers they've
used both you know their own money their
own power they View advocacy groups like
the NRA that help open markets for the
US and to beat back gun control in other
countries and they've also used the
power of the US government
a regulatory change begun under the
Obama Administration and completed by
the Trump Administration in 2020 gave
gun manufacturers the greater freedom to
export that they'd been looking for
said look we are regulating guns and a
lot of what they call dual use items the
same as you would regulate weapons of
war in some cases it made sense you
shouldn't have to get a license to sell
a screw that might be used in F-16 they
loosen the restrictions and instead of
it going through the state department
it's now handled under Commerce
Department the idea is that guns just
like any other us-made product Commerce
sees part of its roles to help sell
those things they do that with planes
they do that with whiskey they do it
with all sorts of products but when they
did this they also included very
controversial weapons the AR-15s the 50
caliber guns that the cartels are using
in Mexico and can shoot through engine
blocks
those are now treated as commercial
items
so where do these guns end up well it's
probably important to note that most
countries in the world don't want to buy
U.S guns because most countries in the
world have relatively strict gun laws
and so you have this mix of U.S guns
going to places with a lot of
instability and not the strongest hold
on democracy
tracking gun shipments is very difficult
because they don't put much data out and
what they put out is very complicated
you need a license to export guns from
the US in order to get the license you
have to have approval of the country
where the weapons are going to go where
the guns go once they end up in those
countries are you know a total different
matter in Mexico there's one gun store
and there's hundreds of thousands of
guns that go to the Mexican police and
military but a lot of those guns later
end up in the hands of cartels or
paramilitary groups in Thailand there's
pretty strict gun control on the record
but the black market is so widespread
that people advertise on Facebook and
Twitter to sell guns illegally over the
last few years there have been all-time
highs in U.S gun exports
foreign
[Music]
things is that there is an increase in
violence where a lot of the exports are
increasing and you've got to be careful
you know correlation is not causation
but in some places like Latin America
they say that about 20 of the crime guns
recovered were legally exported if you
talk to people in Guatemala and Honduras
they say a lot of the migrant crisis at
the U.S border is being fueled by the
fact that there's just rampant Street
crimes and and cartels and Drug violence
and there's so many guns there and the
U.S is sending more guns in Mexico for
instance they say less than two percent
of crime guns are legally from the U.S
but Mexico only submits a very small
portion of overall crime guns to be
traced but it is clear that significant
number of the
crime guns in other countries are legal
exports rather than illegal
along with guns manufacturers are doing
their best to spread the culture around
guns as well
in order to sell more guns
internationally is these gun
manufacturers gun lobby they want to
export American Gun culture as well
which is you know owning a gun is a
right to as violence increases in places
like Central America and elsewhere that
the best way to counter that violence is
to arm Ordinary People so that they can
defend themselves
six hour for example has something
called the Sig Academy they will fly
people over and let them try a lot of
different guns shoot guns at the same
time they they're in the U.S they travel
business class it's a nice trip they'll
also do a lot of sponsorships for police
departments for events and that creates
a sort of a relationship between the gun
manufacturers and the buyers in these
countries
there are instances where legally
exported American Guns can be proven to
have been used in mass killings in
foreign countries
so one of the things we started to do is
look at the sales of U.S guns abroad and
one of the things that popped up
immediately is that Thailand buys more
U.S guns than just about any other
country
a lot of those guns has come through
this unique program called the gun
welfare program Thai police didn't have
very many guns and the guns they did
have were old and didn't work very well
so they negotiated with six hour and
other companies uh pretty good prices
for the guns the police would buy them
as personal guns and then use them when
they were in the forest
problem is that that warped the market
so rather than just buy one of them
people started by two or three of them
and then you have an investment you
could sell them so these guns sort of
flooded the country we followed one in
particular which was a p365 that six
hours sold to a policeman in 2021 and
that policeman was later fired for using
drugs and ended up using that gun in the
worst mass shooting in Thailand's
history
36 people were killed it's a small tiny
little village 24 of them were children
it's not only one of the worst mass
shootings in Thai history it's one of
the worst mass shootings in the world
period
the prospects for reigning in profligate
gun exports might be slim but increasing
restrictions could be surprisingly
simple
the president can do it with the stroke
of a pen the whole time the regulation
was going through was the president's
decision to no longer regulate certain
Weapons Under the U.S Munitions list so
President Biden you could do it tomorrow
the political wrath he would face from
businesses from advocacy groups would
probably be ferocious Joe Biden for
example made a promise in his election
campaign where he said if I get elected
I will take this 2020 rule change and
I'll just reverse it
here we are 2023 he's running for a
second term that reversal hasn't
happened
so even as the rest of the world is
looking with horror at the situation
with the gun crime and the mass
shootings in the U.S the U.S is
loosening restrictions and exporting
more guns than ever around the world
[Music]